على الحدود الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه اعلن
حزب الله انه استهدف موقع بياض بليده
بالاسلحه
الصاروخيه وانه حقق اصابه مباشره كذلك
اعلن حزب الله قصفه ب 62 صاروخا قاعده
ميرون الاسرائيليه في اطار ما وصفه بالرد
الاولي على اغتيال صالح العاروري ورفاقه
واشار الحزب الى ان قاعده ميرون تعتبر
مركز الاداره والمراقبه والتحكم الجوي
الوحيد في شمال اسرائيل وتشكل مركزا
لعمليات التشويش الالكتروني كما اعلن
الحزب عن استهداف موقع المطله وسكنه هونين
الاسرائيليين وقال مراسل الجزيره ان
الطائرات الاسرائيليه شنت غاره على محيط
بلدتي عيت الشعب وعدي سه وقصفت مسيره بلده
يارون كما تعرض محيط بلدات الخيام وميس
الجبل وحوله
وبليد
وحيب لقصف مدفعي
[موسيقى]
اسرائيلي هذا وكان الجيش الاسرائيلي اعلن
ان سلاح الجو استهدف مواقع لحزب الله
ومنصات صواريخ في بلدات يارون وراميه وعيت
الشعب جنوب لبنان وكان المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي قال انهم رصدوا اطلاق نحو 40
صاروخا من لبنان باتجاه منطقه جبل
الجرمق الجليل في الجليل الاعلى وذكرت
القناه الثانيه عش الاسرائيليه ان صفارات
الانذار دوت في
94 بلده ومدينه على الحدود معل لبنان
بينها صفد وكرمل في الجليل ومن ناحيتها
قالت هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ان الجيش قرر
اغلاق كافه الطرق والشوارع على طول الحدود
مع
لبنان ومن مرج عيون جنوب لبنان ينضم الينا
مراسلنا جوني طانيوس ومن الجليل الاعلى
تنضم الينا مراسلتنا فاطمه خمايسي ونبدا
معك جوني لنعرف يعني هذه الجبهه واضح انها
تشهد تصعيدا كبيرا ضعنا في صوره ما يجري
من الجانب اللبناني
تفضل صحيح ليلى التوتر والتصعيد هو
العنوان الابرز هنا في المناطق الحدوديه
الجنوبيه هناك الكثير من العناوين والنقاط
التي يمكن التوقف عندها في سياق احداث هذا
اليوم ولكن بدايه لابد من الاشاره الى
ثلاث غارات نفذتها المقاتلات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه قبل بعض الوقت على نقطه واقعه
بين بلدتي الشرقيه وكوثر السياد باتجاه
محافظه النبطيه وهي مناطق بعيده نسبيا عن
المناطق الحدوديه تقع الى شمال منطقه
الليطاني وهي المره الاولى منذ السابع من
اكتوبر الماضي التي تطال فيها الغارات
الاسرائيليه الحربيه نقاط بعيده الى هذا
المدى عن المناطق الحدوديه ونحن بالتالي
ازاء تطور كبير لناحيه الغارات الجويه
الاسرائيليه التي شنت كما ذكرت قبل بعض
الوقت في تلك المنطقه وربما ايضا قد يكون
ذلك مرتبط بالعمليات العسكريه التي نفذها
حزب الله خلال ساعات هذا اليوم وابرزها
العمليه الاولى التي اعلن عنها وقال انها
جاءت كرد اولي على عمليه اغتيال صالح
العاروري في الضاحيه الجنوبيه لبيروت في
اي حال حزب الله اليوم اعلن عن تنفيذه
اربع هجمات باتجاه المواقع العسكريه
الاسرائيليه موقع المطلي موقع بياض بليده
ولكن يبقى الابرز والاهم هذه العمليه التي
نفذت باتجاه مقر جبل ميرون وهو مقر
القياده والتحكم والرصد الجوي قدم حزب
الله شرحا مسهبا بشان هذه القياده وهذه
النقطه التي استهدفها والاهميه
الاستراتيجيه والعسكريه لهذه المنطقه وهذه
النقطه العسكريه التي استهدفها ب 62
صاروخا من انواع متعدده و بالتالي هذا
التطور ايضا كان لافتا جاءت هذه العمليه
خارج سياق العمليات التي نفذها وينفذها
حزب الله من الجنوب اللبناني دعما واسناد
لقطاع غزه كما يقول بشكل متكرر الغارات
الاسرائيليه خلال ساعات هذا اليوم كانت
عنيفه على بلدات مختلفه ا كانان عيتا
الشعب او يارون او بلده برج الملوك
القريبه من النقطه التي نحن فيها بالاضافه
الى غارات اخرى نفذت ايضا في نقطه واقعه
على الطريق بين بلدتي العديسه ورب
الثلاثين هناك قصف مدفعي سجل طوال ساعات
هذا اليوم باتجاه بلدات مختلفه في بعض
الاحيان استخدم الجانب الاسرائيلي القذائف
الحارقه التي يعتقد المتابعون انها قذائف
فسفوريه وتحديدا بلده الخيام التي تقع
خلفنا
مباشره ض ال هذا المشهد طبعا التحق
المستمر ل جوني فقط بشكل مختصر استهداف
صيده للمره الاولى بغارات اسرائيليه ضعنا
في صوره تفاصيل هذا
[موسيقى]
الخبر كما ذكرت في بدايه هذه الرساله
المستجد الذي لابد من التوقف عنده هي
الغرات الثلاث التي وقعت بين بلده الشرقيه
من جهه النبطيه وبلده كوثر السياد الواقعه
في قضاء صيدا هي مناطق بعيده عن الحدود هي
المره الاولى التي تطال الغارات
الاسرائيليه هذه المناطق حتى الساعه نحن
نتحدث عن ثلاث غارات جويه اسرائيليه على
تلك المنطقه هذا تطور كبير لابد من التوقف
عنده لابد من قراءه ابعاده كما ذكرت ربما
يكون مرتبط بالعمليات التي نفذها حزب الله
وبالتالي اقدام حزب الله صباحا على
استخدام 62 صاروخا لاستهداف المقر الواقع
في جبل ميرون ربما يرد عليه الجانب
الاسرائيلي الان من خلال غارات اكثر عمقا
في الداخل اللبناني واكثر عمقا باتجاه
مناطق قريبه من او بعيده عن الحدود
الجنوبيه التي نحن فيها الامر الذي اردنا
اذا التركيز عليه اشكرك جوني اذا فاطمه
كما اشار جوني للتو يعني التركيز غارات
اسرائيليه تستهدف منطقه بين بلدتي كوثر
السياد والشرقيه في قضاء الصيده جنوب
لبنان ماذا تقول اسرائيل بهذا
الخصوص نعم في البدايه ليلا دعيني انوه
الى انه خلال حديث جوني كانت صفارات
الانذار تدوي في منطقه شتوه في الجليل
الغربي وعلى ما يبدو انه تم استهداف هذه
المنطقه
بشقه صاروخيه ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لا يوجد
اي تفاصيل اضافيه حول هذا الحدث ولكن هذا
يقع ضمن المواجهه التي تحصل هنا في الجبهه
الشماليه وفي اطار التوتر الذي شهدته
الجبهه هنا منذ ساعات الصباح نحن نتحدث عن
قيام الجيش الاسرائيلي بشن سلسله غارات
جويه في الاراضي اللبنانيه وقال انه
استهدف كما هي عادته دوما مراصد تابعه
لحزب الله مواقع عسكريه وبنى تحتيه وايضا
منصات لاطلاق الصواريخ في كل من منطقه
عيتا الشعب يارون
وراميا وبالتالي هذا يقع ايضا في اطار
الرد على الرشق الصاروخيه التي التي
استهدفت جبل الجرمق صباح هذا اليوم باكثر
من 40 صاروخ وايضا نتحدث عن رشقات اخرى
متفرقه واطلاق للمسيرات من الاراضي
اللبنانيه باتجاه مواقع مختلفه في
الجليلين الغرب والاعلى كانت قبل نصف ساعه
ايضا دوي صفارات الانذار في الجليل الغربي
والدفاعات الجويه اعترضت مسيره اطلقت من
الاراضي اللبنانيه وبالتالي الجبهه شهدت
هنا عمليات متتاليه كبيره جدا ومتسارع منذ
ساعات الصباح وحتى هذه اللحظه ايضا تم تم
استهداف عفوا موقع عسكري في بلده المطله
واللافت هو استعمال الجيش الاسرائيلي لاول
مره منذ اندلاع هذه الحرب لمن طاد مرا قبه
يعرف باسم ندى السماء وهو احد انظمه
الدفاعات الجويه المتقدمه جدا في هذه
المواجهه وهذا المنطاد يتمتع باجهزه
مراقبه عاليه جدا ترصد الحركه سواء
القادمه من الاراضي السوريه او الاراضي
اللبنانيه تكتيك جديد اذا يستعمله الجيش
الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك فاطمه الخمايسي